have you ever dreamed of having your own
vegetable garden at home a garden that
yields a bounty of fresh vegetables each
one more delicious and nutritious than
the last well dream no more with a
little bit of knowledge some effort and
a lot of love you too can create a
vegetable garden that is both productive
and delectable first off the choice of
vegetables is Paramount consider your
local climate the size of your garden
and your personal preferences some
vegetables such as tomatoes peppers and
cucumbers thrive in warm sunny climates
others like lettuce spinach and kale
prefer cooler temperatures once you've
chosen your vegetables it's time to
plant them start with highquality seeds
or seedlings plant them in well-
draining soil enriched with organic
matter such as compost or well- rotted
manure remember different vegetables
have different planting depths and
spacing requirements so be sure to
follow the instructions on the seed
packets next care for your plants as
they grow water them regularly ly but
avoid overwatering as this can lead to
root rot keep an eye out for pests and
diseases and deal with them promptly and
organically also remember to weed your
garden regularly weeds compete with your
vegetables for nutrients water and
sunlight so it's essential to keep them
under control as your plants grow they
may need support Stakes cages or
trellises can be used for this purpose
they help keep your plants upright
prevent diseases by improving air
circulation and make harvesting easier
when it's time to harvest do so with
care use sharp clean tools to avoid
damaging the plants some vegetables like
zucchini and beans should be harvested
young and tender others like tomatoes
and peppers should be allowed to ripen
on the plant for maximum flavor in
summary creating a productive and
delicious vegetable garden involves
choosing the right vegetables planting
them correctly caring for them as they
grow providing support when needed and
harvesting them at the right time with
these steps you can turn your dream of
home vegetable garden into a delicious
reality remember the key to a successful
vegetable garden is patience care and a
love for nature so why not start your
vegetable garden today after all there's
nothing quite like the taste of a fresh
homegrown vegetable happy
gardening